absolutely Bonkers I go to Starbucks
that I haven't been to in a while years
I walk into the Starbucks first of all
on the patio no furniture which there's
always like people hanging out I walk
inside no furniture no furniture in
Starbucks but it's well open
so I walk up I want to get a salad they
don't have salad so I'm like oh now I
came here for no reason and I'm pissed
but at least I can gain information I'm
curious where the [__] is the furniture
so I say to the lady hey
um
why is there no furniture in here and
she said man
we've been having so many incidents
that upper management just told us we
can't have furniture
dude I didn't realize how funny this is
until I'm talking about it
can't even have furniture anymore
because we can't have people in here and
I was like so you just
you just you can come in and sell and
get coffee and you got leave and she's
like yeah
I'm like whoa dude
the world is going to [__]
Starbucks can't even have furniture
anymore
what are incidents too you know it has
to do with like homeless people [__]
on the floor and like fights
like fighting and
oh God
oh my god dude
this is so crazy
they can't have furniture Starbucks
getting furniture anymore
it wasn't even like it was like Vineland
and Ventura
it was just some place that you might be
like oh cool Starbucks you're going no
furniture
I should have just sat on the floor and
drank a [__] iced espresso crazy
[Music]